we want to win right now while we're
alive and we also want to set up the
structure for the club to continue to
win long after we're dead unless there's
a meteor in which case we're all yeah
leave it to ryan reynolds to take an
innocent presser for his welsh soccer
club wrexham afc and turn it into
something deadpool would be proud of i
was about to say that's being streamed
live on itv world's apologies for the
language there chris you're excited oh
my gosh i have no idea i'm so sorry no
it's fine welcome
welcome to wales and nothing but class
coming out
now ryan along with his co-owner rob
mcelhenny spoke to welsh press about
what they're most looking forward to
accomplishing while owning the club
something that's really impressed me
personally is that you've employed a
woman who's a chief exec now you're
you've put your money into the women's
game you're supporting disability and
lgbtq rights to be honest that's
refreshing in football do you feel that
your kind of experience in a different
sector has made you want to do that and
make not only wrexham a better place but
football a better place as well
yeah it's good for the for the game i
mean it's really inclusivity is always
good for any industry and certainly the
film industry that's been that's been
the case and and
you know both of these industries are
have similarities that we both have a
long way to go with respect to that so
we're thrilled that we can
you know add to that in any way if this
was a movie what would be your perfect
ending
why i mean you know
we'd be lying it wasn't premier league
or something like that but it's a this
is a long road you know it's not this
isn't an overnight thing so our our goal
is to get us back in the league and and
and continue our way upwards and that's
that's going to take some time so yeah i
don't think that
we don't reticent to get into the pie in
the sky type of stuff but the the
perfect endings promotion you know and
the guys were sure to let the people of
wrexham know the thing they're most
looking forward to is getting to know
the community and their town of course
the sport had a lot to do with it but it
was more about the community and it was
more about how much i recognized and
identified with
not the people on the pitch because
believe me i'm nothing like the people
on the pitch but i'm
exactly like the people in the stands
and i and i remember looking up on the
screen and saying i know those people i
am those people i'm related to those
people and i think we can do something
special um and it wasn't until i called
ryan before my wife was like oh okay
that's a good idea
i i've been really
taken and surprised with how emotionally
invested
my family but also my friends and my
colleagues have become have have become
with wrexham in particular um they're
following it they're looking you know
when there's a match on they're watching
online as best they can or they're or
they're following on social media so you
know that that's
there's something incredibly contagious
about it and you know i certainly am not
i don't profess to be a football expert
in any way shape or form but um i see
the the the sort of the beauty of the
fandom